What would it take to speak so well that
people think you're always brilliant
even when you don't have a script and
you're winging your presentations on the
fly? Ali Abdaal knows the answer to this
question. He has over 6 million YouTube
subscribers, a New York Times
best-selling book, but he wasn't born a
great speaker. And I know this because
we've taught Ali's speaking system to
thousands of non-professional speakers
and we even worked directly with Ali
himself to level up his speaking style
and share it with his own students.
[music] So, by the end of this video, I
am confident that you'll know the
secrets behind how Ali stays confident
and avoids rambling whenever he speaks.
Two, never finds himself stuck without
something interesting to say no matter
what he's talking about. And three, how
he avoids freezing or falling back into
presenter mode even in front of an
audience thousands of people. But before
we can unpack the secret behind each of
these, we need to start by answering
just one question. If Ali's not
scripting when he talks, then what is he
doing? There is no way to make reading
from a script sound not like reading
from a script. And we've all seen
people, you know, at at speeches and
stuff where they look down, they've got
the notes and they the way they deliver
it, it's obvious that they're reading
from a script. [music] They
automatically go into British Airways
mode. This is basically not the way
forward. So, Ali basically throws away
90% of the scripting out the window. We
script the first 30 seconds of the video
through the hook and then we just have
talking points. So, often a video's a
video will just look like this. It will
just be like a little spider diagram or
it'll just be a few talking points. A
few talking points. It's a rough idea
and it's a lot of riffing.
But if you're in a similar situation,
you might start to lose your way. You
might start to ramble.
And that's the biggest risk of this
method. But Ali does something really
interesting. Watch this clip from one of
Ali's videos with over 2 million views
where he's giving advice on how to
achieve financial freedom. Watch what he
does. Similarly, a lot of people I know
who work at startups,
uh not the incredibly high growth really
stressful kind, but you know, a small
company, bit of a lifestyle business,
also really enjoy their jobs and have a
lot of happiness and fulfillment even
though technically they are financially
chained to an employer. [music] So, the
reason I'm saying all of this stuff is
because
when it comes to this desire for
financial freedom, we really want to
understand why.
What are we going for here? Okay, did
you catch that? The reason I'm saying
all this stuff is because
Ali's deep in the weeds talking
startups, happiness, fulfillment and
then So, the reason I'm saying all of
this stuff is because And boom, he
pivots back to the main idea asking you,
why do you really want financial freedom
anyway?
And look how cool this is. YouTube has
these graphs that show you when
attention spikes in a video and you can
literally see on the graph as people
stop to lean in right when Ali uses the
phrase, the reason I'm saying this stuff
is because. He's literally queuing the
audience to tune back in. And here's
later in the same video. And so, by the
time you're getting to three, four, four
and a half K a month, the sort of person
you are is no longer content with just
the five K a month. And so, the goal
becomes 10 K a month or 20 K or 50 K or
100 K or a million a month. That was a
bit of a tangent, but the point is,
let's pick a number and let's then
figure out what we need to get there.
So, that was a bit of a tangent, but the
point is, let's pick a number.
It's not that Ali's somehow immune to
rambling and it's not even that he edits
out all the bad takes. The point is, his
secret is that he has a way to get back
on track in the moment.
We call this technique
the summary prompt. Summary prompts are
any phrase that signals to you and your
audience and your listener that you're
about to give them the main message.
Summary prompts are like this reset
button for your brain.
You don't need to know what you're going
to say next. All you have to do is just
start saying the prompt. The point is,
my point is, the reason I'm saying this
is, and then magically your brain's
going to come up with a summary for you.
And that's what people are going to
remember. They remember the summary, not
all the rambling that happened before.
And Ali does this all the time. So, what
you basically have is that a system is
The thing that I found that actually
moved the needle is So, basically it
serves So, basically just comes down to
The thing to take away from this Most
things around learning can basically be
summed up by those The key reason, the
one that trumps everything else [music]
and again, the whole point of this video
is the So, the reason I'm saying all of
this stuff is because So, coming full
circle, the point is But the point is
But the point is And what makes this so
powerful is that Ali's not scripting
this. He's not scripting the prompt or
the response.
He discovers them in real time.
He actually lets himself explore and go
on tangents and follow his curiosity and
then when he realizes, wait, I've been
going on for too long, that's when he
uses a summary prompt to bring him back.
And you can use these just as easily.
All you have to do is practice noticing
when you're off track.
And when you do, prompt yourself with a
phrase to return back to the main idea.
If you do this, your brain is going to
fill in what comes next.
Now, if I'm being completely honest,
if this is all Ali had Ali had were the
prompts,
maybe he'd still fall flat on his face
in some situations because the thing is
prompts only work if you actually have
something to say. How does he come up
with all of these ideas on the fly
without a script? If we want to answer
this question, we need to examine how
Ali talks about the same topics in three
completely different formats. The first
video is 43 seconds. Ali has to move
fast and most of us, if we're honest,
we're watching this in the bathroom most
likely on a break waiting in line for
something. But video number two is 14
minutes long.
Ali gets way more into the topic and in
this case, he's riffing on examples of
things that are going to keep you from
achieving financial freedom. And video
number three is 1 hour long.
It's an actual recording of Ali talking
live. He fills the entire hour, takes
questions, riffs without losing energy,
without losing enthusiasm.
Each of these videos is covering very
similar topics, but they go into
different levels of depth. So, how does
he do this?
How can he talk about a similar topic at
wildly different levels of depth with no
memorization? Well, instead of
memorizing,
Ali internalizes.
That's the key word, internalizes. In a
way, Ali's books, his YouTube channel
and his courses, they're expressions of
the same deeply internalized idea. What
we just saw is that YouTube itself
forces you to present ideas differently
based on how much time is available.
What this trains
is your ability to talk about the same
ideas on the fly without needing to
re-plan or prepare.
And once Ali understands the North Star
of his ideas, he basically gets to
expand or compress those ideas to fit
what his current format needs. Now, you
don't need a YouTube channel to do this.
In fact, there's a simple exercise that
can take mere minutes that you can use
to build this exact skill. I love this
exercise. We call it the accordion
method.
You just take a topic that you know
well, but isn't polished yet. It's still
a little bit confusing in your mind. If
you had to speak on it, you feel like
you would run in circles a little bit.
What you're going to do here is you're
going to practice expressing it at
different lengths. So, say you'd say
you'd work on 5 minutes. You might start
at 5 minutes, then 2 minutes, then 30
seconds. So, you're compressing the
accordion. And then you do 30 seconds, 2
minutes and 5 minutes opening the
accordion again. What you're doing here
through this process is that you're
internalizing your core ideas so that
they become so deeply internalized that
you could present them at any length
without having to rewrite or re-prepare.
The point is in doing these big jumps,
you are preventing
your brain from memorizing your content
word for word and you're matters,
>> [music]
>> the essence of what you want to say. Ali
does this process naturally across
thousands of videos.
But you can do this on your own. If you
want, you can check out the free guided
exercise in our description below. But
Ali Abdaal's speaking success
is more than summary prompts and
internalization.
There's actually a final factor that
pulls everything together.
And without it, you might argue that
everything else Ali does would crumble.
There are basically two modes, two
different modes of speaking on camera.
There is number one, the confident
presenter
and there is number two, the casual
coffee chit-chat. It's when I usually
have a glass in my hand and I'm kind of
talking like this. Hey friends, welcome
back to the channel. In this video, I
want to share my thoughts about why I
decided to quit medicine. And you know,
to be honest, it was a bit of a
difficult decision. I, you know, I've
been really struggling with this for the
last 7 years.
You know, it's it's this sort of
slightly lower energy, a bit more
low-key as if I'm kind of confiding in a
friend and I'm treating the camera as if
as if the camera was my therapist
almost.
>> If there's one thing that makes people
freeze more often than anything else
when speaking, it's the feeling of
performing. The moment you think, I'm
presenting this, your brain shifts into
presenter mode or as Ali calls it,
British Airways mode. It's tragic to see
someone start presenting and you see
everything that makes them interesting
in real life just vanish.
And so, Ali's solution is pretty simple.
Don't think of it as a presentation,
think of it as a conversation with a
friend. You've got you, the camera just
right over here, sitting across a coffee
table from me. We're having a cup of tea
or coffee. I'm kind of talking to you
like I I to a friend if I was kind of
going a little bit deeper, being a
little bit more intimate, and just sort
of speaking in the way that I would if
this were a chat over coffee just with a
probably a little bit more intonation
than I normally would in real life
because I do tend to mumble a bit and
speak quite fast in real life.
>> At Ultra Speaking, we have a phrase.
Energy leads and content follows.
Because it's really hard to force your
words to sound relaxed. The more you
force them, the less relaxed you're
going to look and the less relaxed
you're going to feel. So, instead, you
have to remind yourself to speak
conversationally. [music]
It's like a mental trigger to access a
state where you naturally feel relaxed.
You naturally feel thoughtful and
friendly. And once you're there,
the words will flow much more naturally
from that feeling. The goal here is to
learn how to feel like yourself in any
scenario. Whether it's with a camera in
front of your face,
on a stage in front of an audience, or
leading a presentation. Great speaking
is not about eliminating mistakes. This
is so important. It's about making
mistakes and trusting yourself to
recover. Kevin Kelly says this
beautifully, one of my favorite quotes.
Pros are just amateurs who know how to
gracefully recover from their mistakes.
And here's Ali practicing this concept
using an exercise called triple step,
which comes directly from our Ultra
Speaking program. Take a look. So,
again, my friends at Ultra Speaking,
they have this Ultra Speaking simulator
that gives you lots of interesting
games. And so, I'll show you what one of
these looks like. And the idea here is
that we've got to give a speech about a
random topic and then we've got to
incorporate the words from that are
appearing on screen as they're coming on
screen.
The color of life.
To be honest, I think the color of life
is blue. Blue is my favorite color and I
find that, for example, if I'm running a
marathon, I see the blue sky and it
really helps me it helps me focus. If I
roll the windows down in my blue Tesla,
again, it allows me to feel the breath
in my face even when I'm going to the
toilet or I having just been for a round
of horse racing, I just feel the color
blue everywhere around me. It's sort of
like an engine. When you when you have
the perfect color, you can feel as if
you're like a Ferrari engine driving
down the road. Um even if you're like
voting uh for popsicles or you know,
whatever. It's It's just a color in the
sky. It feels like the color of luck.
That's scary. That's hard.
>> [laughter]
>> But, these sort of games, good way of
improving public speaking. When you are
forced to speak with zero preparation
about an oddball topic,
you have to give up on making perfect
sense. There's just no other way.
Instead, your new goal is just to stay
in character,
own your energy, and trust the words
will come.
This is how Ali Abdaal can riff on
bullet points for 60 seconds or 60
minutes without ever losing his way.
If you want to dive deeper, check out
the description to improve your own
speaking in any situation. And if you
want to see how a speaker who rambles
way more than Ali, yet still manages to
move markets and inspire millions, you
can watch my full video breakdown of
Elon Musk's speaking. I love this one.
Watch it next
right here.